hi this is the fourth lesson of the AWS
Solutions Architect course migrating to
the cloud doesn't mean that resources
become completely separated from the
local infrastructure in fact running
applications in the cloud will be
completely transparent to your end-users
AWS offers a number of services to fully
and seamlessly integrate your local
resources with the cloud one such
service is the Amazon virtual private
cloud this lesson talks about creating
virtual networks that closely resemble
the ones that operate in your own data
centers but with the added benefit have
been able to take full advantage of AWS
so let's get started
you
in this lesson you'll learn all about
virtual private clouds and understand
their concept you'll know the difference
between public private and elastic IP
addresses you'll learn about what a
public and private subnet is and you'll
understand what an Internet gateway is
and how it's used you'll learn what
route tables are and when they are used
you'll understand what and that gateway
is we'll take a look at security groups
and their importance and we'll take a
look at Network ACLs and how they're
used in Amazon VPC also review the
Amazon VPC best practices and also the
costs associated with running a B PC in
the Amazon Cloud welcome to the Amazon
virtual private cloud and subnet section
in this section we're going to have an
overview of what Amazon V PC is and how
you use it and we're also going to have
a demonstration of how to create your
own custom virtual private cloud we're
going to look at IP addresses and the
use of elastic IP addresses in AWS and
finally we'll take a look at subnets and
there'll be a demonstration about how to
create your own subnets in an Amazon V
PC and here are some other terms that
are used in V pcs there's subnets root
tables elastic IP addresses Internet
gateways NAT gateways Network ACLs and
security groups and then the next
sections we're going to take a look at
each of these and build our own custom V
PC that we'll use throughout this course
Amazon defines a V PC as a virtual
private cloud that enables you to launch
AWS resources into a virtual network
that you've defined this virtual network
closely resembles a traditional network
that you'd operate in your own data
center but with the benefits of using
the scalable infrastructure of AWS a V
PC is your own virtual network in the
Amazon Cloud which is used as the
network layer for your ec2 resources and
this is a diagram of default B PC now
there's a lot going on there so don't
worry about that what we're going to do
is break down each of the individual
items in this default V PC over the
coming lesson but what you need to know
is that a V PC is a critical part of the
exam and you need to know all the
concepts and how it differs from your
own networks throughout this lesson
we're going to create our own V PC from
scratch which you'll need to replicate
at the end of this so you can do well in
the exam each V PC that you create is
logically isolated from other virtual
networks in the AWS cloud it's fully
customizable you can select the IP
address range create subnets configure
root tables setup network gateways
define security settings using security
groups and network access control lists
so each Amazon account comes with a
default V PC that's pre-configured for
you to start using straight away so you
can launch your ec2 instances without
having to think about anything we
mentioned in the opening section a V PC
can span multiple availability zones in
a region and here's a very basic diagram
of a V PC it isn't this simple in
reality and as we saw in the first
section here's the default Amazon V PC
which looks kind of complicated but what
we need to know at this stage is that
the CIDR block for the default V PC is
always a 16 subnet mask so in this
example it's 172 3100 / 16 what that
means is this V PC will provide up to
65,536 private IP addresses so in the
coming sections we'll take a look at all
of these different items that you can
see on this default V PC but why
wouldn't you just use the default V PC
well the default V PC is great for
launching new instances when you're
testing AWS but creating a custom V PC
allows you to make things more secure
and you can customize your virtual
network as you can define your own our
IP address range you can create your own
subnets that are both private and public
and you can tighten
new security settings by default
instances that you launch into a V PC
can't communicate with your own network
so you can connect your V pcs to your
existing data center using something
called hardware VPN access so that you
can effect of the extend your data
center into the cloud and create a
hybrid environment now to do this you
need a virtual private gateway and this
is the VPN concentrator on the Amazon
side of the VPN connection then on your
side in your data center you need a
customer gateway which is either a
physical device or a software
application that sits on your side of
the VPN connection so in you create a
VPN connection a VPN tunnel comes up
when traffic is generated from your side
of the connection VPC peering is an
important concept to understand appear
in connection could be made between your
own V pcs or with a V PC in another AWS
account as long as it's in the same
region so what that means is if you have
instances in V PC a they wouldn't be
able to communicate with instant is in V
PC B or C and less you set up appear in
connection peering is a one-to-one
relationship a V PC can have multiple
peering connections to other V pcs but
and this is important transitive peering
is not supported in other words V PC a
can connect to B and C in this diagram
but C wouldn't be able to communicate
with B unless they were directly paired
also v pcs with overlapping CI DRS
cannot be paired so in this diagram you
can see they all have different IP
ranges which is fine but if they have
the same IP arranges they wouldn't be
able to be paired and finally for this
section if you delete the default V PC
you have to contact AWS support to get
it back again so be careful with it and
only delete it if you have good reason
to do so and know what you're doing this
is a demonstration of how to create a
custom V PC
you
so here we are back at the amaz
services management console and this
time we're going to go down to the
bottom left where the networking section
is I'm going to click on V PC and the V
PC dashboard will load up now there's a
couple of ways you can create a custom V
PC there's something called the V PC
wizard which will build V pcs on your
behalf from a selection of different
configurations for example a V PC with a
single public subnet or a V PC with
public and private subnets now this is
great because you click about and type
in a few details and it does the work
for you however you're not going to
learn much or pass the exam if this is
how you do it so we'll cancel that and
we'll go to your V pcs and we'll click
on create a V PC and we're presented
with the create a V PC window so let's
give our V PC a name I'm going to call
it simply learn underscore V PC and this
is the kind of naming convention I'll be
using throughout this course next we
need to give it the CIDR block or the
classless inter-domain routing block so
we're going to give it a very simple one
10.0.0.0 and then we need to give it the
subnet mask so you're not allowed to go
larger than 15 so if I try to put 15 in
it says no not going to happen for in
reference subnet mask of 15 would give
you around 130 1000 IP addresses and
subnet 16 will give you 65,536 which is
probably more than enough for what we're
going to do next you get to choose the
tenancy there's two options default and
dedicated if you select dedicated then
your ec2 instances will reside on
hardware there's dedicated to you see
performance is going to be great but
your cost is going to be significantly
higher so I'm going to stick with
default and we just click on yes create
it'll take a couple of seconds
and then in our BPC dashboard we can see
our simply learned vp c has been created
now if we go down to the bottom here to
see the information about our new VP C
we can see it has a root table
associated with it which is our default
route table so there it is
and we can see that it's only allowing
local traffic at the moment we go back
to the VP C again we can see it's being
given a default Network ACL and we'll
click on that and have a look and you
can see this is very similar to what we
looked at in the lesson so it's allowing
all traffic from all sources inbound and
outbound now if we go to the subnets
section and just widen the VPC area here
you can see there's no subnets
associated with the vp c which is
created so that means we won't better
launch any instances into our vp c and
to prove it
I'll just show you we'll go to the ec2
section so this is a glimpse into your
future this is what we'll be looking at
in the next lesson and we'll just
quickly try and launch an instance we'll
select any instance it doesn't matter
any size not important so here the
network section if I try and select
simply learned EPC is saying no subnets
farmed this is not going to work
so we basically need to create some
subnet in our V PC and that is what
we're going to look at in the next
lesson
now private IP addresses are IP
addresses that are not reachable over
the internet and they used for
communication between instances in the
same network when you launch a new
instance is given a private IP address
and an internal DNS hostname that
resolves to the private IP address of
the instance but if you one connect to
this from the Internet
it's not going to work so then you'd
need a public IP address which is
reachable from the internet you can use
public IP addresses for communication
between your instances and the Internet
each instance that receives a public IP
address is also given an external DNS
hostname public IP addresses are
associated with your instances from the
Amazon pool of public IP addresses when
you stop will terminate your instance
the public IP address is released and a
new one is associated when the instance
starts so if you want your instance to
retain this public IP address you need
to use something called an elastic IP
address an elastic IP address is a
static or persistent public IP address
there's allocated your account and can
be associated to and from your instances
as required an elastic IP address
remains in your account until you choose
to release it there is a charge
associated with an elastic IP address if
it's in your account but not actually
allocated to an instance this is a
demonstration of how to create an
elastic IP address
so we're back at the Amazon where
this management console we're going to
head back down to the networking VPC
section and we'll get to the VPC
dashboard on the left hand side will
click on elastic IPS now you'll see a
list of any elastic IPS that you have
associated in your account and remember
any the elastic IP address that you're
using that isn't allocated to something
you'll be charged for so I have one
available and that is allocated to an
instance currently so we want to
allocate a new address and it reminds
you that there's a charge if you're not
using it I'm saying yes allocate and it
takes a couple of seconds and there's
our new elastic IP address now we'll be
using this IP address to associate with
than that gateway when we build that
AWS defines a subnet as a range of IP
addresses in your B PC you can launch
AWS resources into a subnet that you
select you can use a public subnet for
resources that must be connected to the
Internet and a private subnet for
resources that won't be connected to the
Internet the net mask for the default
subnet in your V PC is always 20 which
provides up to 4096 addresses per subnet
and a few of them are reserved for AWS
use the PC can span multiple
availability zones but the subnet is
always mapped to a single availability
zone this is important to know so here's
our basic diagram which we're now going
to start adding to so we can see the
virtual private cloud and you can see
the availability zones and now inside
each availability zone we've rated a
subnet now you won't be able to launch
any instances unless there are subnets
in your B PC so it's good to spread them
across availability zones for redundancy
and failover purposes there's two
different types of subnet public and
private you use a public subnet for
resources that must be connected to the
Internet for example web servers a
public subnet is made public because the
main route table sends two subnets
traffic that is destined for the
Internet to the internet gateway and
we'll touch on Internet gateways next
private subnets are for resources that
don't need an internet connection or
that you want to protect from the
internet for example database instances
so in this demonstration we're going to
create some subnets a public and a
private subnet and we're going to put
them in our custom VPC in different
availability zones
so we'll head to networking and
PC wait for the V PC dashboard to load
up will click on subnets will go to
create subnet and I'm going to give the
subnet and name so it's good to give
them meaningful names so I'm going to
call this first one for the public
subnet ten dot zero dot one dot zero and
I'm going to put this one in the US east
one B availability zone and I'm going to
call it simply learn public so it's
quite a long name I understand but at
least it makes it clear for what what's
going on in this example so we need to
choose a V PC so we obviously want to
put it in our simply learned V PC and I
said I wanted to put it in US East one B
I'm using the North Virginia region by
the way so we click on that then we need
to give it the CIDR block now as I
mentioned earlier when I typed in the
name that's the range I want to use and
then we need to give it the subnet mask
and we're going to go with 24 which
should give us two hundred and fifty-one
addresses in this range which obviously
is going to be more than enough if I try
and put a different value in that's
unacceptable to Amazon is going to say
this can give me an error and tell me
not to do that let's go back to 24 and
click and a cut and paste this by the
way just go I need to type something
very similar for the next one
click create it takes a few seconds okay
so there's our new subnet and I'll just
widen this you can see so that's the IP
range that's the availability zone it's
for simpler than an its public so now we
want to create the private so I'm put
the name in I'm going to give the
private the IP address block that I'm
going to put this one in u.s. the east
one see
and it's going to be the private sub now
obviously I wanted to be in the same be
PC by the bit is using of us the East 1c
and we're going to give it 10.0 2.0 - 24
and will click yes create again it takes
a few seconds okay let me sort by name
so we can see now we've got our private
subnet and our public seven air right
let me just type in simply learnt that
we are so now you can see them both
there and you can see they're both in
the same V PC simply learn V PC now if
we go down to the bottom you can see the
root table associated with these V pcs
and you can see that they can
communicate with each other internally
but there's no internet access so that's
what we need to do next in the next
lesson you're going to learn about
Internet gateways and how we can make
these subnets have internet access
you
welcome to the networking section in
this section we're going to take a look
at Internet gateways route tables and
NAT devices and we'll have a
demonstration on how to create each of
these AWS VPC items
you
so to allow your VPC the ability to
connect to the internet you need to
attach an Internet gateway and you can
only attach one Internet gateway pervy
pc so attaching an Internet gateway is
the first stage in permitting Internet
access to instances in your V PC now
here's our diagram again and now we've
added the Internet gateway which is
providing the connection to the Internet
to your V PC but before you can
configure internet correctly there's a
couple more steps for an ec2 instance to
be internet connected you have to adhere
to the following rules firstly you have
to an attach an Internet gateway to your
V PC which we just discussed then you
need to ensure that your instances have
public IP addresses or elastic IP
addresses so they're able to connect to
the internet then you need to ensure
that your subnets root table points to
the Internet gateway and you need to
ensure that your network access control
and security group rules allow relevant
traffic to flow to and from your
instance so you need to allow the rules
to let in the traffic you want for
example HTTP traffic after the
demonstration for this section we're
going to look at how route tables access
control lists and security groups are
used in this demonstration we're going
to create an Internet gateway and attach
it to our custom V PC
you
you
so let's get a networking EPC bring up
the VP see dashboard and on the left
hand side we click on Internet gateways
so here's a couple of Internet gateways
I have already but I need to create a
new one so create Internet gateway I'll
give it a name which is going to be
simply learn Internet gateway igw now
I'm going to click create so this is an
Internet gateway which will connect a V
PC to the Internet
because at the moment our custom V PC
has no internet access so there it is
created
simply than i GW but this state is
detached because it's not attached to
anything so let me try and attach it to
a V PC and it gives me an option of all
the V pcs that have no internet gateway
attached to them currently so I only
have one which is simply than V PC yes
attached now you can see our V PC has
internet attached and you can see that
down here so let's click on that and it
will take us to our V PC but before any
instances in our V PC can access the
Internet
we need to ensure that our subnet root
table points to the Internet gateway and
we don't want to change the main root
table we want to create a custom root
table and that's what you're going to
learn about next
you
a room table determines where network
traffic is directed it does this by
defining a set of rules every subnet has
to be associated with a route table and
a subnet can only be associated with one
route table however multiple subnets can
be associated with the same route table
every VPC has a default route table and
it's good practice to leave this in its
original state and create a new route
able to customize the network traffic
routes associated with your VPC so
here's our example and we've added two
route tables the main route table and
the custom route table the new route
table or the custom route table will
tell the internet gateway to direct
Internet traffic to the public subnet
but the private subnet is still
associated to the default route table
the main route table which does not
allow Internet traffic to it all traffic
inside the private subnet is just
remaining local in this demonstration
we're going to create a custom route
table associate it with our internet
gateway and associate our public subnet
with it
you
you
so let's go to networking and be PC
- bulb will load and we're going to go
to round tables now our V PC only has
its main round table at the moment the
default one it was given at the time it
was created so we want to create a new
root table and we want to give it a name
so we're going to call it simply learn
we call it root table
RVT for sure and then we get to pick
which V PC we want to put it in so
obviously we want to use simply learn V
PC so we click create we'll take a
couple of seconds and here you are
here's our new root table so what we
need to do now is change its root so
that it points to the Internet gateway
so if we go down here to root at a
minute you can see it's just like our
main root table it just has local access
so we want to click on edit and we want
to add another root so the destination
is the Internet is all the zeros and our
target and we click on this it gives us
the option of our Internet gateway which
we want to do so now we have internet
access to this subnet Tory to this root
table and we click on save save was
successful so now we can see that as
well as local access we have internet
access now at the moment if we click on
subnet associations you do not have any
subnet associations so basically both
both our subnets the public and private
subnets are associated with the main
root table which doesn't have internet
access so we want to change this will
click on edit and we want our public
subnet to be associated with this root
table so click on save so it's just
saving that so now we can see that our
public subnet is associated with this
route table and this route table is
associated with the Internet gateway so
now anything we launch into the public
subnet will have internet access but
what if we wanted our in
instances in the private subnet to have
internet access well there's a way of
doing that with an app device and that's
what we're going to look at in the next
lecture
you
you can use an app device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the internet
or rubber AWS services but prevent the
internet from initiating connections
with the instances in the private subnet
so we talked earlier about public and
private subnets to protect your assets
from be directly connected to the
Internet for example your web server
would sit in the public subnet in your
database in the private subnet which has
no internet connectivity however your
private subnet database instance might
still need internet access or the
ability to connect to other AWS
resources if so you can use a network
address translation device or an app
device to do this and that device
forwards traffic from your private
subnet to the internet or other AWS
services and then sends the response
back to the instances when traffic goes
to the Internet the source IP address of
your instance is replaced with the NAT
device address and when the Internet
traffic comes back again then that
device translates the address to your
instances private IP address so here's
our diagram which is getting ever more
complicated and if you look in the
public subnet you can see we've now
added and that device and you have to
put NAT devices in the public subnet so
that they get internet connectivity AWS
provides two kinds of NAT devices and
that gateway and in that instance AWS
recommends in that gateway as it's a
managed service that provides better
availability and bandwidth than that
instances each NAT gateway is created in
a specific availability zone and is
implemented with redundancy in that zone
and that instance is launched from a NAT
ami an Amazon machine image and runs as
an instance in your V PC so is something
else you have to look after
whereas in that gateway being a fully
managed service means once it's
installed you can pretty much forget
about it and that gateway must be
launched into a public subnet because it
needs internet connectivity it also
needs an elastic IP address which you
can select at the time of launch
once created you need to update the root
table associated with your private
subnet the point internet bound traffic
to the NAT gateway this way the
instances in your private subnet can
communicate with the Internet so if you
remember back to the diagram when we had
the custom root table which was pointed
to the Internet gateway now we're
pointing our main root table to the NAT
gateway so that the private subnet also
gets internet access but in a more
secure manner
welcome to the create and that gateway
demonstration where we're going to
create an that gateway so that the
instances and our private subnet can get
internet access
so we'll start by going to Network
VPC and the first thing we're going to
do is take a look at our subnets and
you'll see why shortly so here are
simply learn subnets this is the private
subnet that we want to give Internet
access
but if you remember from the section
that gateways need to be placed in
public subnets so I'm just going to copy
the name of this subnet ID for the
public subnet and you'll see why in a
moment so then we go to NAT gateways on
the left-hand side and we want to create
a new NAT gateway so we have to put a
subnet in there so we want to choose our
public subnet as you can see it
truncates a lot of the subnet names on
this option so it's a bit confusing so
we know that we want to put it in our
simply learn VPC in the public subnet
but you can see it's truncated so it's
actually this one at the bottom but what
I'm going to do is just paste in the
subnet ID which I copied earlier so
there's no confusion then we need to
give it an elastic IP address now if you
remember from the earlier demonstration
we created one so that select that but
if you hadn't allocated one you could
click on the create new VIP button so
we'll do that okay so it's telling me my
NAT gateway has been created and in
order to use you on that gateway ensure
that you edit your route table to
include a route with a target of and
then on that gateway ID so it's given us
the option to click on our edit route
tables so we'll go straight there now
here's our here's our route tables now
here's the custom route table that we
created earlier and this is the default
the main route table which was created
when we launched out when we created our
BPC so we should probably give this a
name so that we know what it is so we
just call this simply learn RTB main so
now we know that's our main route table
so if you
look at the main root table and the
subnet associations you can see that our
private subnet is associated with this
table so what we need to do is put a
root in here that points to the NAT
gateway so if we click on routes and
edit and we want to add another root and
we want to say that all traffic can
either go to the simply man Internet
gateway which we don't want to do we
want to point it to on that instance
which is this and that ID here and we
click Save so now any instances launched
in our private subnet will be able to
get internet access via around that
gateway
you
welcome to the using security groups and
network ACL section in this section
we're going to take a look at security
groups and network ACLs and we're going
to have a demonstration on how you
create both of these items in the Amazon
Web Services console the security group
acts as a virtual firewall that controls
the traffic for one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that add our traffic to or from its
associated instances basically a
security group controls the inbound and
outbound traffic for one or more ec2
instances security groups can be found
on both the ec2 and V PC dashboards in
the AWS web management console we're
going to cover them here in this section
and you'll see them crop up again in the
ec2 lesson and here is our diagram and
you can see we've now added security
groups to it and you can see that ec2
instances are sitting inside the
security groups and the security groups
will control what traffic flows in and
out
so let's take a look at some examples
and we'll start with a security group
for a web server now obviously a web
server needs HTTP and HTTPS traffic as a
minimum to be able to access it so here
is an example of the security group
table and you can see we're allowing
HTTP and HTTPS the ports that are
associated with those two and the
sources and we're allowing it from the
Internet we're basically allowing all
traffic to those ports and that means
any other traffic that comes in on
different ports would be unable to reach
the security group and the instances
insider
let's take a look at an example for a
database server security group now
imagine you have a sequel server
database then you would need to open up
the sequel server port so that people
can access it which is port 1433 by
default so we've added that to the table
and we've allowed the source to come
from the internet now because it's a
Windows machine you might want to RDP
access so you can log on and do some
administration so we've also added RDP
access to the security group now you
could leave it open to the internet but
that would mean anyone could try and
hack their way into your box so in this
example we've added a source IP address
of 10.0.0.0 so only IP arranges from
that address can RDP to the instance now
there's a few rules associated with
security groups by default security
groups allow all outbound traffic so if
you want to tighten that down you can do
so in a similar way to you can define
the inbound traffic security group rules
are always permissive you can't create
rules that deny access so you're
allowing access rather than denying it
security groups are stateful so if you
send a request from your instance the
response traffic for that request is
allowed to flow in regardless of the
inbound security group rules and you can
modify the rules of a security group at
any time and the rules are applied
immediately
welcome to the create security group
demonstration where we're going to
create two security groups one the host
DB servers and one the hosts web servers
now if you remember from the best
section it said it was always a good
idea to tear your applications into
security groups and that's exactly what
we're going to do so if we go to
networking and be PC to bring up the V
PC dashboard on the left hand side under
security we'll click on security groups
now you can also get to security groups
from the ec2 dashboard as well so here's
a list of my existing security groups
but we want to create a new security
group and we're going to call that
simply learn web server SG security
group and we'll give the group name is
the same and our description is going to
be simply learn web servers security
groups okay and then we need to select
our B PC now it defaults to the default
V PC but obviously we want to put it in
our simply learn V PC so click yes
create takes a couple of seconds and
there it is as our new security group
now if we go down to the rules the
inbound rules you can see there are none
so by default a new security group has
no inbound rules
what about outbound rules if you
remember from the lesson a new security
group by default allows all traffic to
be outbound and they are all traffic has
destination of everywhere so all traffic
is allowed we want to add some rules so
let's click on inbound rules click on
edit now this is going to be a web
server so if we click on the drop down
we need to give at HTTP so you can
either choose custom TCP rule and type
in your own port ranges or you can just
use the ones they have for you so HTTP
this pre-populates the port range and
then here you can add the sauce now if I
click on it it's given me the option to
saying allow access from different
security groups so you could create a
security group and say I only accept
traffic from a different security group
which is a nice way of securing things
down you could also put in here just
your IP address
so that only you could do HTTP request
to the instance but because it's a web
server we want people to better see our
website otherwise it's not going to be
much used so we're going to say all
traffic so all source traffic can access
our instance on port HTTP 80 I want to
add another all because we also want to
do HTTP which is hiding from me now we
are and again we want to do the same and
also because this is going to be a Linux
instance we want to be able to connect
to the Linux instance to do some work
and configuration so we need to give it
SSH access and again it would be good
practice to tie it down to your specific
IP or an IP range but we're just going
to do all for now and then we click on
save and now we are there we have our
ranges so now we want to create our
security group for our DB servers let's
click create security group and then
we'll go through and give it a similar
name simply learn DB servers st and the
description is going to be simpler than
TV servers security group and our V PC
is obviously going to be simpler than
the PC let's click yes pray wait a few
seconds and here's our new security
group as you can see it has no inbound
rules by default and outbound rules
allow all traffic so this is going to be
a sequel server a database server and so
we need to allow sequel server traffic
into the instance so we need to give it
Microsoft sequel port access now the
default port for Microsoft sequel server
is 1433 now in reality I'd probably
change the port the sequel server is
running on to make it more secure but
we'll go over this for now and then the
source so we can choose the IP arranges
again but what we want to do is place
the DB server in the private subnet and
allow the traffic to
come from the web server so the web
server will accept traffic and the web
server will then go to the database to
get the information it needs to display
on its web on the website or if people
are entering information into the web
site we want the information to be
stored in our DB server so basically we
want to say that this the DB servers can
only accept sequel server traffic from
the web server security group so we can
select the simply then web server
security group has the source traffic
but Microsoft sequel server data so
we'll select that now our sequel server
is also going to be a Windows instance
so from time to time we might night what
we might need to log in and configure it
so we want to skip RDP access now again
you would probably put a specific IP
range in there we're just going to do
all traffic for now then we click Save
and there we are
so now we have two security groups DB
servers and web servers
a network ACL is a network access
control list and it's an optional layer
of security for your V PC that acts as a
firewall for controlling traffic in and
out of one or more of your subnets you
might set up Network ACLs with rules
similar to your security groups in order
to add an additional layer of security
to your V PC here is our network diagram
and we've added Network ACLs to the mix
now you can see they sit somewhere
between the root tables and the subnets
this diagram makes it a little bit
clearer and you can see that a network
ACL sits in between a root table and a
subnet and also you can see an example
of the default network ACL which is
configured to allow all traffic to flow
in and out of the subnets to which its
associated each network ACL includes a
rule whose rule number is an asterisk
this rule ensures that if a packet
doesn't match any of the other numbered
rules is denied you can't modify or
remove this rule so if you take a look
at this table you can see on the inbound
some traffic would come in and it would
look for the first rule which is 100 and
that's saying I'm allowing all traffic
from all sources so that's fine the
traffic comes in if that rule 100 wasn't
there it would go to the asterix rule
and the Aztecs are all is saying traffic
from all sources is denied let's take a
look at the network ACL rules each
subnet in your V PC must be associated
with an ACL if you don't assign it to a
custom ACL it will automatically be
associated to your default ACL a subnet
can only be associated with one ACL
however an ACL can be associated with
multiple subnets an ACL contains a list
of numbered rules which are evaluated in
order starting with the lowest as soon
as a rule matches traffic is supplied
regardless of any higher numbered rules
that may contradict ur AWS recommends
incrementing your rules by a factor of
100 so there's plenty of room to
implement new rules at a later date
unlike security grooves ACLs are
stateless responses to allowed inbound
traffic a subject to the rules for
outbound traffic
welcome to the network PCL demonstration
but we're just going to have an overview
of ACLs where they are in a dashboard
you
now you don't need to know a huge amount
about them for the exam you just need to
know how they work and where they are so
let's go to networking and VPC and on
when the dashboard loads on the left
hand side under security there's Network
ACLs let's click on that now you can see
some ACLs that are in my my AWS account
so we want the one that's associated
with our simply learned V PC so if we
extend this V PC column that's our
network ACLs simply then V PC now let's
give it a name because it's not very
clear to see otherwise also I'm kind of
an obsessive tagger
so it's call it simply learn ACL and
click on the tick so yeah so now it's
much easier to see so click on inbound
rules so this is exactly what we showed
you in the lesson the rule is 100 so
that's the first rule that's going to
get evaluated and is saying allow all
traffic from all sources and the
outbound rules are the same so if you
wanted to tighten down the new rule you
could click Edit we've give it a new
rule number say which would be 200 so
you should always increment them in 100
so that means if you have 99 more rules
you needed to be put in place you would
have space to put them in in between
these two and then you could do whatever
you wanted you could say you know we are
allowing HTTP access from all traffic
and we're allowing or you could say
actually you know what we're going to
deny it so this is the way of
blacklisting traffic into your V PC now
I'm not going to save that because we
don't need it but this is where the
network ACL set and this is where you
would make any changes it's also worth
having a look at the subnet associations
with your ACL so we have two subnets in
our simple env PC so we would expect to
see both of them associated with this
network ACL because it's the default and
there they are it's both our public and
our private subnets are associated and
you can also see up here on the on the
dashboard it says default so this is
telling us this is our default ACL if
you did want to create a new network
ACLU would click
right Network ACL you've give it a name
just saying new ACL and then you would
associate it with your V PC so we would
say simply then DPC takes a few seconds
and now we are there we have our new one
you can see this one says default no
because it obviously isn't the default
ACL file are simply Len V PC and it has
no subnets associated with it so let's
just delete that because we don't need
it but they are there's a very brief
overview of network PC else
welcome to the Amazon VPC best practices
and costs where we're going to take a
look at the best practices and the costs
associated with the Amazon virtual
private cloud always use public and
private subnets you should use private
subnets
to secure resources that don't need to
be available to the Internet such as
database services to provide secure
internet access to the instances that
reside in your private subnets you
should provide an app device when using
that devices you should use in that
gateway over nat instances because there
are managed service and require less
administration effort you should choose
your cidr blocks carefully Amazon VPC
can contain from 16 to 65,536 IP
addresses so you should choose your CIDR
block according to how many instances
you think you'll need
you should also create separate Amazon v
pcs for development staging test and
production or create one Amazon V PC
with separate subnets with a subnet each
for production development staging and
tests you should understand the Amazon V
PC limits there are various limitations
on the V PC components for example
you're allowed 5 B pcs per region 200
subnets per VPC 200 route tables per V
PC 500 security groups per V PC 50 in
and outbound rules per V PC however some
of these rules can be increased by
raising a ticket with AWS support you
should use security groups and network
ACLs to secure the traffic coming in and
out of your V PC Amazon advises to use
security groups for whitelisting traffic
and network ACLs the blacklisting
traffic Amazon recommends tearing your
security groups you should create
different security groups for different
tiers of your infrastructure
architecture inside V PC if you have web
tears and DB tears you should create
different security groups for each of
them creating tear wise security groups
running
the infrastructure security inside the
Amazon VPC so if you launch all your web
servers in the web server security group
that means they'll automatically all
have HTTP and HTTPS open conversely the
database security group will have sequel
server pots already open
you should also standardize your
security group naming conventions
following a security group naming
convention allows Amazon VPC operation
and management for large scale
deployments to become much easier always
span your Amazon VPC across multiple
subnets in multiple availability zones
inside a region this helps in
architecting high availability inside
your VPC if you choose to create a
hardware VPN connection to your B PC
using Virtual Private Gateway you are
charged for each VPN connection hour
that your VPN connection is provisioned
and available each partial VPN
connection hour consumed is billed as a
full hour you'll also incur standard AWS
data transfer charges for all data
transferred via the VPN connection if
you choose to create an that gateway in
your V PC you are charged for each NAT
gateway hour that you're on that gateway
is provisioned and available data
processing charges apply for each
gigabyte processed through than that
gateway each partial nap gateway hour
consumed is billed as a full hour this
is the practice assignment for designing
a custom V PC where you will create a
custom V PC using the concepts learned
in this lesson using the concepts
learned in this lesson
recreate the custom V PC as shown in the
demonstrations the V PC name should be
simply learned V PC the CIDR block
should be 10.0.0.0 slash 16 it should be
2 subnets 1 public with a range of 10.0
1.0 and one private of a range of 10 0
to 0 and they should be placed in
separate availability zones there should
be one Internet gateway and one nap
gateway
and also one custom root table for the
public subnet also create two security
groups simply then web server security
group and simply learn DB server
security group so let's review the key
takeaways from this lesson
Amazon virtual private cloud or VPC
enables you to launch AWS resources into
a virtual network that you've defined
this virtual network closely resembles a
traditional network that you'd operate
in your own data center but with the
benefits of using scalable
infrastructure of AWS there are three
types of IP address in AWS a private IP
address this is an IP address that's not
reachable over the Internet and it's
used for communication between instances
in the same network a public IP address
is reachable from the internet which you
can use for communication between your
instances and the internet and there's
an elastic IP address this is a static
public persistent IP address that
persists after an instance restarts
whereas a public IP address is risked
associated after each restart Amazon
defines a subnet as a range of IP
addresses in your B PC you can launch
AWS resources into a subnet that you
select and a subnet is always mapped to
a single availability zone use a public
sub natural resources that must be
connected to the Internet and a private
subnet for resources that won't be
connected to the Internet to allow your
V PC the ability to connect to the
internet you need to unattach an
Internet gateway to it and you can only
attach one Internet gateway / V PC a
root table determines where network
traffic is directed it does this by
defining a set of rules every subnet has
to be associated with a root table and a
sudden that can only have an association
with one root table however multiple
subnets
can be associated to the same root table
and you can use a NAT device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the internet or other AWS services
but and that device will prevent the
internet from initiating connections
with instances inside your private
subnet a security group acts as a
virtual firewall that controls the
traffic for one or more instances you
add rules to each security group that
allow traffic to or from
it's associated instances a network
access control list or network ACL is an
optional layer of security your V PC
that acts as a firewall for controlling
traffic in and out of one or more of
your subnets
this concludes the Amazon VPC lesson the
next lesson is Amazon ec2